ANNA GORDON: I'm
Anna Gordon, one
of the co-founders
of Clara & Jack.
Clara & Jack is a
new nursing brand
for breastfeeding mothers.
The real challenge
with creating a startup
is that you're suddenly
everything in that company.
I'm used to working
in a huge institution
where, if I don't
know something,
I go and ask for
somebody who does, right?
So if I don't know about
producing a television program,
I know a lot of
people who can tell me
about producing a
television program.
And I think running a
startup, you suddenly
realize that you have to
have much more confidence
and the drive to go out and find
information out for yourself
and take on the role
that you need to,
whether that's
the manufacturing,
whether it's the
press and PR role,
whether it's the HR
role, whatever it is.
You've got to take
all those functions.
And it's given me much
greater confidence.
One of the speakers
talked about the need
to really test your
market before you've even
spent any money.
And we walked away from
that going, you're right.
We think there's an opportunity.
And our friends think
there's an opportunity.
But that's not the only
people we want to sell to.
We want to sell to
many more than that.
So we actually pulled
together a survey
that we got out,
shared on social media.
And within 48 hours, we
had over 400 responses,
which was fantastic.
That gave us a real boost
as well, to say actually,
there is interest and
demand for our product
out there before
we've even started.
And it also gave us some
really detailed feedback
about why people
buy nursing bras,
where do they go, what's
most important to them
in terms of comfort,
or style, or fit.
So that gave us a real
starter to develop the product
that we wanted to,
before we'd even
spent any money on creating
a product, which was great.